des bruits ont été captés en provenance
des profondeurs marines dans cette zone
autour de l'épave du Titanic des coûts
répétés toutes les 30 minutes
susceptibles de redonner un peu d'espoir
nous n'avons qu'un seul bouton c'est
tout comme dans un ascenseur j'ai eu ça
dans un magasin pour le camping on
contrôle tout ça avec une manette de
jeux vidéo il faut signer une décharge
avant de monter à bord de ce sous-marin
et la mort est mentionnée à trois
reprises en page une ce ne sont pas des
vacances en autocar ça peut mal tourner
vous êtes enfermé de l'extérieur il y a
18 boulons en cercle autour de la trappe
et d'ailleurs ils n'en ont attaché que
17 le 18e est très haut et ils disent
qu'il n'y a vraiment aucune différence
mathématique
un exigeant de l'entreprise a été
licencié après avoir émis des doutes sur
la sécurité du submersible l'un des
hublots serait certifié pour résister à
une pression jusqu'à seulement 1300
mètres et non 4000 mètres de profondeur
d'explosion qui s'est déroulée en plein
cœur de Paris euh cet immeuble qui s'est
effondré une première explosion suivie
d'un incendie sur deux immeubles
l'explosion concerne cet immeuble en
rouge les flammes se sont propagées aux
deux bâtiments mitoyens situés en face
nous avons donc le 7 victimes qui sont
en urgence absolue et nous avons 9
victimes qui sont en urgence relative
j'insiste bien sur le fait que nous donc
c'est un bilan provisoire car il y a
encore des recherches qui se déroulent
sous les décombres les débris continuent
de s'effondrer
le collectif écologiste les soulèvements
de la Terre a été dissout ce matin au
Conseil des ministres l'annonce en a été
faite par le Ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald de Darmanin qui portait cette
demande ce n'est pas davantage des idées
qui sont sanctionnées c'est le recours
répété à la violence contre des biens
contre des personnes qui étaient
renouvelées à plusieurs occasions ces
dernières semaines le gouvernement
persiste
qui relève un peu de fantasmatique
pranoïaque de ce qu'est la réalité du
mouvement des soulèvements de la terre
les soulèvements de la terre c'est quoi
aujourd'hui c'est la Ligue des droits de
l'Homme la Confédération paysanne Europe
Écologie Les Verts des fermes ou des
poteaux à recours mais nous contestons
ne serait-ce que l'appellation du
groupement de faits des soulèvements de
la terre parce que les soulèvements de
la terre c'est un mouvement qui est
horizontal c'est un mouvement qui est
protéiforme et c'est un mouvement que
nous qui ne peut à notre sens être
dissout c'est Cyril Dion qui dont on
connaît tous les documentaires sur le
vivant ils vont quoi ils vont ils vont
ils vont faire comment ils vont
dissoudre toutes ces tous ces gens ils
vont nous interdire au travail ensemble
cette espèce de de foutage des
frontières constant dans ce gouvernement
qui cherche maintenant à expliquer qu'il
y a des éco terroristes pour chercher à
disqualifier le message écologique me
paraît hautement coupable c'est une
dérive inacceptable de la part du
gouvernement de vouloir dissoudre toute
association qui en fait
oserait exprimer des vues contraires
c'est le jour le plus long de l'année
c'est aussi le dernier pour vous
terminus dans quelques heures vous ne
serez plus secrétaire général de la CFDT
ce matin vous le vend qu'est-ce que vous
êtes dit je me suis pas dit que c'était
mon dernier jour
à Laurent Bergé à la tête de la CFDT
depuis 2018 elle était la numéro 2 du
syndicat en charge notamment de dossiers
stratégique comme l'assurance chômage ou
encore les relations inter syndicales
est-ce que vous imaginez dans quatre ans
à les négocier dans le bureau d'un
président de la République qui
s'appellerait Laurent Berger
alors là vous êtes dans la
science-fiction totale je veux aussi te
dire Marylise ma profonde amitié et ma
grande grande sérénité quant à l'avenir
de la CFDT avec toi à sa tête oui je
sais qu'il ne le sera pas voilà et vous
ressortirez cette archive dans 3 ou 4
ans et on en reparlera des filets de
Pharrell Williams pour la maison Vuitton
tenue camouflage et sac à damiers aux
couleurs franches son premier défilé ses
tenu hier sur le pont Neuf à Paris et il
y avait aussi j'ai pas la photo mais il
y avait Anne Hidalgo qui était bien
surpris devant etc parce que ce matin
son adjoint à twitté que c'était une
honte d'avoir privatisé d'avoir bloqué
le quartier pour cet événement c'est un
euro dénouement la cigogne piégée par
une canette de Coca-Cola a été sauvée en
Saône-et-Loire grâce au bon coup d'oeil
d'un groupe d'enfants en sortie scolaire
l'animal affaiblit qui ne s'était pas
alimentée depuis une semaine a été
capturé par les pompiers
qui bloquait Paris on serait vraiment
content c'est pas le cas donc
on se termine